what have you got here one kilo black
truffles you can manufacture diamonds
today but most people don't want those
they want the natural diamond it took
millions of years to make in the Earth
this is this is only by the hand of God
what's very interesting Kevin is
truffles assist in the production of
testosterone no kidding
[Music]
yes hey Marco how are you how are you
wow to bearing gifts oh yeah this is
amazing come on in the kitchen as you
can see I'm making my uh pumpkin pie
right now but what do you got
here one kilo black truffles kilo
paneton infused with balsamic balsamic
vinegar balsamic vinegar and then we're
going to pour some balsamic over top of
it this is the caviar that I'm about to
White Label wow you're making your own
caviar afim from cheese Boutique sent
you uh your favorite cheese he says
that's your your favorite cheese yeah
afraim is the cheese guy I call him
cheese whiz but he's got every kind of
cheese on earth right this is my wife's
uh olive oil oh no kidding extra virgin
certified organic olive oil from
Calabria oh amazing harvested at night
this is the only sustainable organic
Brunello in the world let's not forget
our L fine wine we're going to be
featuring here too so we'll get into
that also this is porini mushroom champo
mushroom black truffle anovi black
olives salt and pepper and extra virgin
olive oil it's like a kind of like a
brusketa we call it a
crma amazing this is truffle caviar
truffle caviar yeah
icha truffle dust truffle
dust that's uh 49 G of white tusin
truffle
and where did this truffle come from
Tuscany oh my goodness hey Chef
wonderful here with Marco the Truffle
man now why are you so famous with
truffles Marco it's just a new passion
to be honest with you I was in the
financial sector before and that's you
were you were not a a chef not
classically trained no well no I was
trained by my mom I spent a lifetime in
the kitchen just like this watching my
mother cook so that's how I learned I I
love Italy I love all things Italian and
I felt like when every time I went to
Italy I wanted to bring stuff back I met
this wonderful family in
Umbria um jeppe and Vanya and they said
you know that we have truffles like
nothing you've ever seen in North
America so I did a little research I
realized that there was nothing like
this and what they produce um in North
America so I thought okay there's a gap
in the market and I'm going to come and
I'm going to bring on a consistent basis
truffles every week now the challenge
with truffles is they are very time
sensitive they don't last forever it's a
matter of weeks if not days right yes
the reason why not too many people do
bring them in is because they're so
perishable such a hard business
logistically getting them here from
Italy on time within a two-day frame
with white truffle you only have five to
maybe seven more days before they lose
all their moisture and then they become
simply a garnish instead of something
that's an aromatic that aromatic and
that flavor that explosion to the nose
when you're shaving it you really want
that experience it's all about the smell
it's all about the invoking of the taste
buds when you smell it a chef will never
tell you that he loves the taste of a
truffle it's really about the way it
smells and and the feeling that it
brings to you when you're about to eat
it now we've got some truffles in here
you've got black and white truffles a
bunch of black and they're sitting on
Rice what's the deal why are we doing
that by the way the aroma is like yeah
it's stopped the madness yeah it's crazy
it's it's wild um
so again the the reason why you would
cover a truffle with um paper towel or
something is because the moisture you
want it to come out and not and you
don't want the water to sit on the
Truffle so you want it to exract some
way the only problem with putting a
truffle in in paper towel is that you
can't eat the paper towel after right
rice on the other hand although it does
draw a little bit more moisture than a
towel would after you could eat the the
the mushrooms letting a single tiny
amount of flavor be lost
later I'm going to cook the rice then
you cook the rice and you make a nice
Roto and you have a truffle rotto even
without the Truffle now I've been told
never touch a truffle with your hands
why is that because they there's there's
a um your hands are dirty even if your
hands are clean they still carry oils
that you'll never be able to get off
your hands and the bacteria that will be
on your hands or anything in the oils
will then transfer to a fungi really
fast it'll go through the whole fungus
and then next thing you know you have
have a soft mushy truffle on your hands
so we're going to use the utensil just
to have a close look at the black
truffle at that a a black truff this is
a black winter truffle this is actually
from Spain it's called a tuber mag it's
it's a Latin name I can't even say it
but it's a fungus but it's a fungus it's
a black truffle so this season is is the
winter season a little bit more
expensive than your normal Summer and
Autumn black truffles because they're
harder to find in the winter especially
in the north of Italy but or the north
of any of you know the where the climate
is colder or there's snow it's harder to
find a black winter truffle so the
harder it is to find a truffle the more
expensive it is okay that's why what
would the cost of this be in let's say
Us doll um about $ 250 per gram and how
many grams is that that's probably about
uh 50 g so 50 *
$250 let's just call it $2 for that's a
$100 it's a $100 $100 us now we have
over here here a white truffle now the
white truffle is a tuber magnet Magnum
the main difference is this black
truffle number one can be cultivated so
you can you can Farm them you can make
them a scientist could make these in a
lab and do they and they do and they do
so that the whole issue around diamonds
you can manufacture diamonds in it but
most people don't want those they want
the natural diamond it took millions of
years to make in the
Earth this is this is only by the hand
of God you find them by the roots of
trees how and they're deeper and how do
you find them dogs what about pigs no
that's a myth pigs are not very agile so
if the ground is flat and a pig's not
going to roll over then a pig can find
it yes but a pig is a lot harder to move
so when a pig finds it he wants to eat
it what's very interesting Kevin is
truffles assist in the production of
testosterone no kidding yes so you
always pick you always have a male dog
dog or male pigs finding the Truffles
and you got to see their tails when they
smell
it so it gets them uh to try yeah yeah
this is uh the Truffle of desire that's
what it is that's fantastic no
traditionally known as an aphrodesiac so
what I'd like to do is to do a tasting
with you MH and so uh what I what I'd
love to do with that tasting is take out
some of my o chardonay crisp exciting
delicious and let's taste yeah let's
taste a little black truffle just raw
how about that mhm that'd be nice and
cuz I you know it could be fun the other
idea I had is we'll try it by itself and
then let's get out of balini get some
caviar put some truffle onto the caviar
and is that debaucherous no it's it's
quite indulgent but I think it' be fun
why don't we do
[Music]
that
so the idea here Marco is you want to
shave a truffle and eat it with a little
fat beautiful the appas is going
in dive dive dive wow isn't that
beautiful that is a gorgeous piece of
cheese it's a little splash of the oir
Chardonnay
you know we should do a watch check here
for a minute cuz I've noticed you're
wearing a nice piece yeah how about that
I'm going with a Richard Mill today for
New York time and of course my one-of
aind AP Shark Tank AP red bands on both
that's La time what are You featuring
there Marco so this is a
Starbucks uh
Rolex uh better known as a Kermit but
for three years they called it a
Starbucks I didn't know that I've always
known it as a Kermit who knew yeah for 3
years for it was limited for 3 years
they called it a Starbucks
this was a gift from the uh my my old
partner when I exited my last company he
bought me this as a gift that's the
whole thing about watches it really
defines a moment in your life that's why
you should have an important piece you
will always remember that in extrating
your business with your old partner
right that's the whole deal that's what
I tell people but do not borrow money to
buy a watch never do that you want to
hear something funny I had a Daytona I
had a stainless steel Daytona white dial
oh it's classic beautiful one and uh at
the time I was kind of you know short on
money and I I met my wife and I wanted
to propose so I sold my Daytona so I
could buy her ring
oh that's l w who who that's crazy too
because you can't get that again that's
your problem that's the problem so he
gives up his steel white face Daytona
the most classic sought after watch in
the world to buy a ring for his wife
yeah I mean that is a what the
moment you got it that's just crazy well
every time I look at that ring and I
look at my wife I remember oh wow I mean
she better still love you for that she
does Mr Wonderful here no one needs a
watch but everybody wants one why
because it marks a moment of time in
your life a graduation a marriage a
successful moment in your career it's
like art many watches appreciate and
value over time and that's where the
problems start you might think your
watch is covered by your home insurance
policy but in many cases that is simply
not true especially if you're looking
for replacement value if your watch is
long are stolen that's why I created
Wonder care want to learn more about
insuring your watch go to wonder
care.com well this is just a your
standard stainless steel shaver you want
it to be a significant size uh when
you're opening it right but you're not
not not too thick cuz you you know then
each each will is there the perfect size
or or diameter or width to a shave of
truffle well the way that you want to do
four shaves per gram so it's easy to
measure in a restaurant so a chef will
go to the table and say here three
shaves
$45 that kind of thing yeah you know so
it's it's really based on three shaves
$45 you don't do this every day off the
block is significantly less money we say
it's like five times less than the than
the white so there's another metric it's
a fifth of price for black versus white
which is the Ed
supro and we know it's very hard to get
and the dogs go crazy yes what about
just don't touch it with your hand
well I'm don't touch it with
your hands before you buy it h cuz once
you buy it it's yours once you own it
it's yours it's yours so first you know
you want to get rid of some of the some
of the non that is the outer skin of the
Truffle yeah so that's the sign bucks oh
my good that's 50 bucks right there so
we're going to try it with black first
right try it with black first so there
you
go
look at that the is a big stinky sticky
cheese are you ready I'm going to wait
for you let's do it
together instead of bread oh my goodness
oh my
goodness that is inred the flavors the
textures that's
insane a little bit of wine
after
oh that is just
amazing
M good wine too oh yeah that's
TR
M that's all about texture flavor the
fat Works beautifully with it full
truffle thing it's just an explosion mhm
you need the fat
if you have employees you need to check
out the ERC program Chef wonderful why
Mr Wonderful because it's cash flow that
you don't have to pay back good to know
this guy's so smart and so handsome go
to wonder trust.com to see if you're
eligible now we're going to take it up a
notch and we're going to go to the white
now the white is five times more
expensive than the black very very time
sensitive give us our we got nine days
with a white no you generally you have
because because of the fact that they're
brought in and then you don't know where
they come from it takes two days to get
generally you have five to seven days
but the we bring them in so fresh that
you have 7 to n Days 7 to n days so
you've got to be really creative with
what you're cooking you're going to be
shaving this it's not as uh tough it's
it's a much lighter experience in terms
of the shave right so I I think for this
experience let me get out some caviar
let me get a balini let's let's put it
on top of caviar with a balini and
experience that whole thing
so I just happen to have some bellinis
so let's get these frozen Bellinis very
high
quality
um take them out we'll put a couple on
the plate what I'm going to do is just
give them a couple of seconds in my
microwave which moistens them it turns
them into
pancake pop that open put them in here
you want to have the utensils when you
build a kitchen like this you want to
design it so everything's close by I
prepare so much food in here it's
insane so what you have to know about
microwave is you have to have a feel for
the
microwave and now myth
no oh perfect mhm all right that's I'm
so good at this it's ridiculous so let
me just show you a dabble do you in the
fridge put it on the balini make it good
it looks very good mhm right and make a
little pocket there for the caviar to go
on
perfect there we go get it yeah
beautiful all right now you're going to
hit him with the
caviar look at that oh smash caviar
baby
not going to be shy with the caviar so
I'll just start off by planing it
because if you don't PL
it wow that's right there is $100 worth
of truffle it looks like a mushroom it's
a fungus oh look at that oh stop the
madness it's white truffle on top of
caviar just say
no all right are we ready here we go oh
I mean this is
just I'll let you go first oh my
goodness yeah look at that here we
go me too me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
too
that's really effing good okay so now
we're going to experiment with the
Truffle paste I leased about 18 hectares
in Calabria so my wife stay at home but
not anymore because now the kids are all
at school yeah so how old are your kids
six five and three a lot of work a lot
of work so now she's back to work back
to work in the sense that we white
labeled an olive oil from Calabria we
Harvest it at night the reason why we
Harvest it at night is because there's
the the temperature is lower in the
olive better for the acidity yeah also
it's if you want to consider it extra
virgin olive oil it needs to be pressed
within 4 hours of being that's the rule
of extrav Virgin 4 hours you pick it at
night less acid crushed in the middle of
the night because the temperature is
lower it takes less time for the for the
Olive to become the right temperature
okay so we crush it at night I want to
introduce you to a varietal that I think
I think you've had sarra before but a
lot of people don't know this wine but
it is if you love Cabernet soeno and you
love Pino you are going to love this
because it's got such a rich profile and
such a spicy aftertaste I call it the
runway like a little air in there try
that wow nice beautiful nice color too
it's beautiful that's beautiful I think
it's going to go so well with this
pairing all right what are we doing here
Marco so what we're going to do now is
so you can see it we're going to put
some of the uh nighttime be oh beautiful
certified organic Extra Virgin Olive Oil
from Calabria and now this is a mix of
white I mean black summer truffle yeah
black olives an
chovi champo and a Pini mushroom
incredible salt and pepper all the
flavors you treat it much like a p like
a a brusketa
wow right look at that go ahead I'll
leave that for you I got to I got to
have a bite of that that's how spell
decoratives oh my goodness yeah
[Applause]
that's wow wow what time is it wow
M it's good beside that that with that
wine really oh my
goodness oh
that okay that's insane isn't that good
that's insane yeah that's our that's our
number one Celler it's got to be the
number one seller that's insane yeah
that's really good yeah and and and you
know when we sample it at a at a show or
something we just put it on bread we
don't even put tomato I love the Tomato
in there because that little acidity on
the bottom and then of course you've got
it blending with that Olive yeah it's
like a
Brisa so let's just summarize what we've
learned today let's go through this
we've explored white truffles and black
truffles and the differences between and
the cost difference 5x difference white
five times more expensive than black
we've learned about the really short
fuse of white truffles as small as 5 to
seven days right we've explored some
amazing derivatives you created like
this paste if I want to call it that
with so many FEA CLA okay which was
spectacular we've tried the truffles
with cheese amazing we've tried it with
caviar on balini and and creme fresh
incredible we' paired it with fantastic
wines and I think what we've really
discussed today is the celebration of
life and family with amazing Foods
right and and and and one more thing
about truffles is you can't find a more
organic more biodiverse product there's
no there's no fooling the Earth it's put
there literally we call it by the hand
of God so where can I get if I whatever
my choice is if I want to get black
truffles I want to get white truffles
truffle kings. Co I sell white and black
truffles consistently every week while
they're in season while they're in
season what are the months what are the
months so for white truffle it's
September to January and for black
truffle all season long all year I be in
Dallas Texas I can be in Boston I can be
in La I'll get them to I'll get them to
and the key what should I know if I'm
just starting out I'm seeing this video
for the first time I'm convinced I want
to try Truffles and all the way Marco
we've tried them today what are you
telling the novice to do just where do I
go to start I would go to a black
truffle a black truffle is the easiest
way to access a truffle taste uh I would
shave it uh fresh on a pasta on a cheese
like we did today uh and then if you
don't need if you if a truffle is not
your thing a black truffle is something
that you're worried about um not being
able to keep it for long enough the chef
shelf life is not us again how many days
that is shelf life on a black truffle is
everywhere from 10 to 14 days and
they're buying from you they want to be
thinking about their meal preparation
for two weeks Max yes yes yes you want
to have it come on time okay you want to
have it come the day and then the next
day you're cooking it and using it in
your meal and the reason why we have the
products and we have the crma and we
have the pearls and we have even this
product over here s right that's all
year long isn't it it's a dust it's a
freeze-dried white truffle dust real
truffle real truffle $3 get that from
you too yes and I can just sprinkle this
on any sprinkle it on anything flavor
yes add it to a fat and the flavor maybe
that's if you really really are budget
conscious start here yeah start there
yeah you can get it from the same place
yep and all the other products so the
the the crema I would say is the one
that delivers the most B what the
website again one more time truffle
kings. truffle kings. if you're just
starting out and you're very budget
conscious you want first time experience
it try the Truffle dust this is a great
idea what does this cost $3 a pocket all
right that's what I'm talking about I
want entry level Marco I want everybody
to try everything same with watches same
ideas start small go big you're starting
with the dust you're going to the black
then you're really on the L supro you're
going for the white truffle which is
expensive expensive but a great
experience in your life 100% do you have
to do it once in your life yeah Mar I've
had a fantastic time with you today you
got to try my s s is beautiful thank you
very much thank you my friend it's you
know it's the holiday season happy
holidays to everybody what a great time
we've had here yeah thank you so much I
and we've learned a lot and it's been an
honor yeah been honor look it's been a
it's been a wonderful time it's been
wonderful that's terrific the key is you
want to eat you want to learn and you
want to enjoy family and friends Marco
to you and here's to you here's to your
family